>> speaker 1: From the Library
of Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Abbey Potter: Well,
do the panelists have any
questions for each other?
>> Marisa Parham: I totally do.
>> Abbey Potter: Yeah?
Okay.
>> Marisa Parham: I was really, so,
I have to change in my whole posture
because I was on the hot seat
and scared, but now I'm like,
oh, I'm asking questions.
But, I was really compelled,
Trevor, by this notion,
the community of practice
is something
that just can't be spontaneous,
and something that takes work.
And, I was just wondering,
with the kind of work you do,
can you say a little
bit more about, sort of,
what those challenges look like?
You said this thing, and it,
I mean, and from the talk,
because your talk was, like, the
bomb, but if I were to step back,
I would say that it was a
little bit out of place,
in the sense that you said this
thing where I was like, you know,
some people might come
to work that day
and not be feeling all
the weight of the world,
of the things happening outside.
And, I thought it was very
telling, an amazing way of, like,
when you're doing the work,
and you're doing the good work,
and you're doing the
work that matters, right?
And then, you're working
with a team,
and everyone doesn't have the
same relation to the work.
Can you say more about that?
>> Trevor Muñoz: Right.
Well, I mean, I think it's, so
one thing I didn't get to say was
that part of sort of trying
to imagine this structure,
and sort of keeping our community
sort of before our eyes is, I think,
to grapple with, you know, the ways
in which our different experiences
are producing the new knowledge
right there as we're having
our different experiences.
And, not to say that that
stuff is outside of the work
that we're doing, but to try
to understand how that comes
into the work we're doing.
And, whether it's my experience that
day, or someone else's experience,
or all of our experiences, to
find out how those different ways
of coming to the work then shape
the work, rather than trying
to draw the boundary, and say, "Oh,
if we only keep all
those things outside,
then we can get on with it."
So, I guess that was
partly what was on my mind.
>> Marisa Parham: Mm-hmm.
Thank you for that.
>> Abbey Potter: You have
a question back here?
>> speaker 2: [inaudible]
>> Abbey Potter: If you
could yell, I'll repeat it.
>> speaker 2: [inaudible]
My question is,
[inaudible] as it applies
to African-American [inaudible]
study African-American [inaudible]
I'm assuming that some of the
limitations may be both quantitative
and qualitative [inaudible]
material not,
that were not even considered
[inaudible] print [inaudible]
collections, and now they're
part of digital collections.
But, there are certain aspects
of information that's missing,
and not included and it
makes it even more difficult
to [inaudible] digital realm.
Can you speak a little bit more
about some of the, I guess,
some of the particular challenges
and nuances that you're facing,
in terms of doing digital
[inaudible] with that type of,
you know, kind of challenged
data sets?
>> Trevor Muñoz: Sure.
I'm, it was actually something
that resonated very much with me
from Marisa's talk, actually, about
thinking about these questions
of deletion in the archive,
and our sort of, our interfaces
to what's deleted or missing,
or what we ourselves need
to protect in the archive.
And so, actually, I wonder if you
have some reflections on this,
as well, but I mean, just as a sort
of general way of saying, I mean,
certainly, you know,
being attuned to looking
for what's not in the records.
You know, that's not a new thought.
But also, sort of trying,
again, to sort of return
to the conversation we were
just having about, you know,
what do I see from my perspective?
What does someone else see
from their perspective?
And, can we sort of piece that data
together, though now I'm trying
to put it together with
this idea of data and datum.
I'm not going to be able
to do it on the fly.
So, certainly there's that.
I mean, thinking about
being conscious of the ways
in which the people who might be
in this archive are in the archive
because they are being represented
there, you know, from, you know,
like, by the state, or
from some other body,
and not in their own control.
And that, you know, maybe we
want to recover their story,
but maybe we also, you know, sort
of don't want to expose, you know,
populations that, you
know, have been sort
of mistreated in certain ways.
And so, there's a lot
of it that goes into it.
I mean, we're really at the
beginning of our process,
and I'm learning from
a lot of my colleagues
about what they're bringing to
this, what they want to look for.
And so, I think we'll have a better
answer for you, you know, in year
or in six months, and we're
really kind of at the beginning.
But, I wonder if you had
any reflections on that.
>> Marisa Parham: Yeah,
I really don't know.
There's so much in that question.
It's the question of translation,
right, between media and thinking
about what happens when
one thing becomes another.
I do think the question
of exclusion, right?
You have exclusion that's sort
of personal agency and choice,
as I was trying to talk about it.
But then, there's also
exclusion as protection,
which I'm really compelled by the
social media stuff I just find,
thinking back to Burgess'
[assumed spelling] talk.
It's just terrifying
to think about, right?
And so, there's a way
in which imagining,
to think about what should
be excluded has to take
into account one, the imagination
the future this archive can produce,
but at the same time,
understand the ways
in which it's always an
artifact of the present.
That's what we're talking about.
We're talking about the problem
of the present, in a way,
when we're talking about exclusion.
It's the person who's
standing there,
who remains, who says
no more, right?
And, I'm sort of babbling around
this, but it's like I'm trying to,
I can sort of see it where we're
trying to, like, I think both of us,
you more so, this is
something you're thinking
about on the ground right now.
So, I guess I am with the Zine
Scenes project, sort of thinking
about what it means to
have to, every moment,
also understand yourself
as a steward, right?
What constitutes good stewardship.
And, at the same time, understanding
that that stewardship
was never necessarily.
Not never.
In many cases, was not
necessarily given to us.
No one handed us stuff and said,
"Please, take these things,
and do this stuff with it," right?
>> Trevor Muñoz: Right.
Yeah, to have humility about
that, about the stewardship.
>> Harriett Green: Right.
>> Marisa Parham: Right.
>> Trevor Muñoz: That was a
theme we heard earlier, as well.
>> speaker 3: When you talked
about the train the trainer
for making libraries more digitally
sufficient, how will you get
in contact with the programs
that are in your local area?
>> Harriett Green: So,
we are reaching out, so,
in terms of our pilot workshops, or?
So yeah, we are, you know, we
have natural contacts already
with librarians who are interested.
We're promoting at least
the pilot workshops.
So, each partner institution
does have plans to not only work
with their own librarians in
the pilots, but also reach
out to their programs,
other programs in the area,
other librarians, and
start bringing them in.
And then, we have started reaching
out to programs and librarians
in the area, so in Atlanta, and
then thinking at major conferences,
and how we partner with libraries.
And so, reaching out both to
digital humanities librarians
in digital scholarship
centers, but also anybody
who has natural inclinations
to be interested in this work.
And, there's a number of outlets
that we'll also reach
out to, as well.
>> Abbey Potter: Any
other questions?
Right here.
>> speaker 4: Also for Professor
Green, and the whole panel.
In your training, there's a lot
of talk about collaboration today.
Have you thought about
training librarians
and the researchers together?
>> Trevor Muñoz: I mean,
certainly that's something
that we're explicitly doing,
and thinking about, you know,
these ideas of mutually informing
expertise and ignorance, going back
and forth among actually the many
different positions of people
in the trainings, rather than, you
know, thinking of it as, you know,
one set of experts clearly
delineated at the front of the room,
communicating to other groups.
So, yeah, we're explicitly
trying to do that.
>> Harriett Green: And, I mean, in
past, like, actually, in general,
HTRC workshops, we do do that
already in our different iterations.
We, you know, teach both librarians
and researchers in our workshops.
And, the idea with the grant, it's
specifically focused and targeted
and mandated for librarians, but
we're definitely anticipating
and trying to develop
the curriculum,
so that librarians are able to
teach researchers and students
across all disciplines, and
from all research questions.
So, it's a actually kind
of interesting challenge
with the curriculum, both addressing
what librarians need to know,
and kind of addressing their
needs, but also thinking through,
how do we enable them to then
train all sort of audiences?
>> Marisa Parham: Yeah.
And, at Five College Digital
Humanities, we have a sort
of very explicit setup where
we very actively encourage,
so we do most of our
training around projects.
So, we develop the training
as projects go along,
so we can develop a sense
of what people need.
Then, we offer just a little bit of
workshop around the edges to get,
you know, whet the appetite so
that people want to learn more,
in terms of bringing their
own sort of subject areas.
But, we have a very explicit rule
about sort of flattening out some
of those relations whenever
possible, so faculty, staff,
and students are equally eligible
to be PIs together on projects.
>> Marisa Parham: And, we
encourage projects that have to work
across campuses and also across
those categories as a way of sort
of emphasizing not only just
collaboration, like, yay, team,
but emphasizing collaboration
of understanding
that those subject positions also
bring different kinds of expertise,
even if they share common
interests, in that that sharing
of expertise is somewhat mandatory.
I hate using that word.
>> speaker 5: [inaudible]
>> Abbey Potter: Okay.
What are they?
Can we have the microphone
down here?
>> Abbey Potter: Thanks.
>> Marisa Parham: [inaudible]
possible [inaudible].
>> Abbey Potter: Just pass it, yeah.
Thank you.
>> speaker 5: Okay, so we just
got, about seven minutes ago,
a tweet came in from Dr.
Hazard [assumed spelling],
and the question is, it's not to
anyone specifically, but in general,
diasporic community as a
practice aren't represented
in cataloging schemes,
tech and digital,
so how do you manage
the levels of those?
Oh, that was a great question.
>> Marisa Parham: Yeah, I mean,
that question's, I'll respond,
because I feel like I was trying
to talk a little bit about that.
It's a challenge.
I think that's the thing
that's sort of why I sort
of said it very quickly
towards the end, but for me,
that's one thing Nbimbe [assumed
spelling], who doesn't really,
is not a digital scholar, but I
think it's incredibly important,
because what Nbimbe is trying to
get us to think about are the ways
in which inclusion is nothing
without a transformation
of the actual structure, right?
So, I think that's absolutely
true, that in many ways,
the practices of various diasporic
indigenous communities are not, or,
even of frankly white, or
what we think of as sort
of mainstream communities, aren't
represented in the interfaces
and ways we use these archives.
But, I do think that when
we're thinking about, you know,
this is the inclusion narrative,
where you just imagine it like,
you know, life is just this big pot,
and if you just get more
different kinds of people in it,
we'll all be okay, right?
And, you know, I can't lie.
It makes me happy.
I want to be in the pot,
like, ooh, the pot, right?
But, at the same time, there's a
way in which, when you're talking
about transformation, by default,
we're thinking about the digital.
It has to be a technical,
structural transformation, right?
So, I'm not trying to dodge
the question, but I do think,
so we have groups that are looking,
for instance, at using Twine,
using different ways of using other
kinds of programs that enable you
to produce interactive interfaces.
Because, I do think
interactivity doesn't sort of solve
or fix everything, but it does get
us a little bit closer to thinking
about sort of the call and
response, and the give and the take,
and whatever it might be from
various communities, right,
that could really be useful
for thinking about the work
of archives in the digital.
>> Abbey Potter: Another
question from Twitter?
>> speaker 5: Yeah.
>> Abbey Potter: Okay.
>> speaker 6: To what degree
are people represented
in archives there voluntarily
or by the will of others,
and how would they
themselves want to be seen?
That's a question from Elise Ingdall
[assumed spelling] on Twitter.
>> Trevor Muñoz: Wow.
[inaudible] the global
answer to that question.
I mean, I think it's certainly true
that we have more, you know, state,
like, collections of state
records, or organization records,
and that the idea of a
sort of community archive,
which is in the control
of those people
who are maybe themselves represented
in it is relatively newer.
That's not a very satisfying
answer to that question.
So, I mean, I think it's a dynamic
that we all need to
be aware of, right?
And, that it shouldn't come as a
surprise, but, for instance, or,
like, some of the work that Jarrett
Drake is doing about thinking
about the differences between
those two types of records,
or those two types of archives,
you know, is informing, I think,
a lot of the conversation right now.
But, I couldn't give a
global answer to that.
>> Marisa Parham: Yeah.
I think, unfortunately,
the answer is just,
very often, they're not, right?
And, I think that goes
to the state thing.
The stuff we have, the
materials that we have the most
of are the things that
were probably collected
in the least desirable ways, right,
which is another thing
to reckon with.
I do think, and not to be
Pollyanna, but I think a lot
of the talks today reflect it.
That's why the work you're
doing is so important,
of just empowering more people to
actually create those collections,
and that would [inaudible]
also technically,
not even just technically
or even collaboratively,
more people to create experiences of
those archives digitally, as well.
Those are two things that both have
to happen, and so, not to just sort
of deflect this question
onto, like, this future,
but I do think it's something
we have to think about,
because at the end of the day, most
of these answers are never going
to sound very good, because
it's not actually a happy past.
>> Abbey Potter: Alright,
so we'll have to end there.
Thank you for sharing your
work and your thoughts with us,
and let's give them
a round of applause.
[ Applause ]
>> speaker 1: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.